figaro live il est 19h51 bienvenue et
merci d'être avec nous en ce mercredi
soir mercredi 14 octobre 2020 on est en
direct sur lefigaro.fr sur twitch et sur
youtube et dans moins de quatre minutes
maintenant on va vivre ensemble et bien
l'interview emmanuel macron le président
de la république va accorder à nos
confrères de tf1 et de france 2 on sera
en direct et on va écouter ensemble bien
les nouvelles mesures qui vont être
annoncées pour lutter contre le regain
épidémique de qu'ovide 19
est ce qu'on peut déjà vous dire à
l'heure qu'il est et bien c'est que
l'état d'urgence sanitaire va être
rétablie à partir de samedi minuit
cet état d'urgence sanitaire il avait
disparu depuis le 10 juillet tout
simplement
et puis alors c'est ce qu'indiquent des
sources concordantes à bfm tv et bien
couvre feu va être instauré de 21h à 6h
du matin dans les villes qui sont en
alerte maximale à savoir paris et la
proche banlieue
lyon marseille lille toulouse ou encore
montpellier on va suivre ça avec plus de
précision dans les minutes qui viennent
on va vous diffusez donc cette interview
et puis ce sont des mesures qui seront
détaillées demain par le premier
ministre jean castex qui a annulé son
déplacement prévu en fin de semaine en
corse un petit bonsoir à patrick wolf
gang bilel falco encore qui sont avec
nous sur notre chaîne youtube bonsoir
également à alain juppé tient qui est
heureux contents de notre retour sur
twitch elle tonton qui est avec nous
bonsoir également opinio fou qui est là
aussi une interview d'une quarantaine de
minutes de la part d' emmanuel macron un
timing qui ne devrait pas être dépassé
pourquoi puisque tf1 diffuse aussi du
foot ce soir c'est l'équipe de france
masculine qui jouent en croatie pour le
compte est bien de la ligue des nations
de football également tf1 diffuseur et
donc tf1 qui ne fera pas jouer les
prolongations ça c'est sûr à manuel
macron merci aussi à julien qui réalise
ce direct toujours ensemble sur
lefigaro.fr twitch et youtube
merci aussi à julie aux réseaux sociaux
qui va enrichir les tchats et modérés
ont des bris fera et bien ces annonces
des manuels macron juste après un rester
avec nous vous pourrez nous poser toutes
vos questions et aussi vos réactions on
les prendra en quelle qu'elle soit
toujours sur youtube switch et
lefigaro.fr et on sera avec marc landré
rédacteur en chef du service économie
france au figaro et bien pour analyser
en 7 cette situation évidemment on va on
va regarder ça sous l'angle et qu on va
attendre que et bien cette confirmation
du couvre-feu viennent du président de
la république lui même et on entendra
marc landré bien quel sera l'impact
évidemment sur et bien l'économie
française on parle souvent de juguler
cette protection de la santé des
français et en même temps cette
préservation de l'économie française
durement touchés on le sait et vis-à-vis
de laquelle les mesures se multiplient à
la ces dernières semaines en vous
diffuse souvent les conférences de
presse du ministre de l'économie et des
finances bruno le maire de phoenix qui
nous rejoint évidemment sur twitch
bonsoir le chat bonsoir à vous on est
surtout il fait évidemment pour vous
diffusez cette conférence de presse une
conférence de presse une interview on a
tout simplement effectivement on sort du
cadre des allocutions qui avait été bien
en vogue lors du printemps en mars en
avril le mois de mai au mois de juin
aussi dernière fois que emmanuel macron
s'est exprimé lors d'une allocution
c'était au mois de juin pour annoncer la
le passage en zone verte des derniers
départements qui étaient encore en zone
orange dont paris par exemple emmanuel
macron qui avait accordé une interview
comme ça à tf1 et france 2 eh bien
c'était le 14 juillet on vous l'avait
diffusée également sur figaro live on va
donc voir ce qu'il en est de ce
couvre-feu qui
être confirmés -un semble-t-il de la
part du chef de l'état 21h06 heures dans
les villes qui sont en alerte maximale
ce qu'on peut vous dire à l'heure
actuelle c'est que son horaire divise
tout comme le fait d'instaurer un
couvre-feu
tout simplement c'est parti pour cette
interview on écoute et on se retrouve
juste après l'apparition de l'épidémie
en france les français sont inquiets ils
sont parfois déboussolée par des
injonctions qui semble contradictoire où
en sommes-nous aujourd'hui en france
est-ce qu'on en est au même niveau qu'à
la mi mars juste avant d'entrer dans le
confinement est ce que on a perdu le
contrôle de l'épidémie
bonsoir nous n'avons pas perdu le
contrôle
nous sommes dans une situation qui est
préoccupante et qui justifie que nous ne
soyons ni inactifs ni dans la panique
nous avons appris de la première vague
notre pays a subi cette vague de plein
fouet un rapport d'ailleurs vient d'être
rendu qui fait l'analyse de ce qu'on a
bien fait moins bien fait mais qui a
frappé toute l'europe le monde entier
même nous avons eues durant cette
première vague
trente mille victimes depuis lors deux
mille victimes supplémentaires
et en effet ce virus que nous
connaissons maintenant depuis le début
de l'année qui nous frappent depuis huit
mois revient nous sommes dans ce qu'on a
souvent appelé cette cette deuxième
vague et ça remonte partout en europe
au moment où nous nous parlons
l'allemagne est en train de prendre
aussi des mesures restrictives parce
qu'elle a beaucoup de cas elle est
quinze jours trois semaines derrière
nous met dans une situation préoccupante
l'espagne les pays bas sont aussi dans
une situation très préoccupante avec
même plus de cas rapportés à leurs
populations que nous et ont pris ces
derniers jours des mesures très
restrictives
donc le virus repart rue circule très
vite partout en europe et dans notre
pays
maintenant je pense qu'il est important
d'aider le début de notre échange et
pour tous nos concitoyens de dire
exactement ce que nous savons de ce
virus on sait qu'ils tuent
l'om est ce le rappelait ce matin 0,6
pour cent des gens qui sont touchés
trente-deux mille victimes en france il
tue plus tôt les gens qui sont plus âgés
c'est vrai que 90% des gens qui sont
morts de nos concitoyens qui sont morts
de ce virus avait plus de 65 ans il
frappe plutôt celles et ceux qui ont
aussi d'autres pathologies un diabète de
l'hypertension de l'obésité mais on peut
aussi ne rien avoir de tout cela et en
mourir et ils frappent de manière très
injuste
encore plus dans les milieux les plus
précaires les plus pauvres mais une fois
que j'ai dit ça ce virus frappent toutes
les catégories d'âge et il ya des formes
très sévère à tous les âges au moment où
je vous parle
s'ils reviendront la moitié de notre la
moitié du nombre de copies qui sont en
réanimation au moins de 65 ans au moment
où je vous parle nous avons des
centaines de milliers de nos concitoyens
qui ont eu ce virus qui en sont sorties
qui sont en train de l'avoir qui en
sortiront mais qui ont perdu l'odorat le
goût qui auront des lésions des poumons
parfois des conséquences cardiaques
gastrique d'autres cérébrale que nous ne
comprenons pas parfaitement donc ce
virus il est dangereux et grave pour
tout le monde
maintenant nous sommes aujourd'hui
rentré dans une phase où en effet il
nous faut réagir
nous mesurons chaque jour mieux on fait
entre 1,3 et 1,4 million de tests par
semaine et en ce moment nous avons vingt
mille car moyenne par jour de plus 20
min au moment où je vous parlais depuis
plusieurs jours nous avons chaque jour
200 nos concitoyens qui rentrent en
réanimation
aujourd'hui 226 et nous avons 32 % de
nos services de réanimation qui sont
occupées par des concitoyens qui ont le
coc vide ce qui veut dire que nos
services de réanimation sont aujourd'hui
dans une situation de pression qui n'est
pas soutenable et ce qui est important
de comprendre et je m'arrêterai là sur
ce point c'est que la différence entre
le moment où je vous parle
est ce qu'on a fait en mars avril c'est
que nous avons appris on sait comment
ils fonctionnent et le virus n'a pas
décollé à ce point donc nous n'avons pas
perdu le contrôle
mais nos urgences nos services
hospitaliers sont dans une situation qui
est plus préoccupante qu alors pourquoi
parce qu'alors le canton nous avons des
défis décidé le confinement le virus
était dans la région grand est et ile de
france
et comme on a tous fermés il s'est très
peu répandu et nous avons pu vous vous
en souvenez répartir des centaines de
patients et nous avons massivement des
programmes et c'est à dire qu'on a
arrêté de faire tout ce qui n'était pas
indispensable pendant des semaines et
des semaines
donc on a libéré des places aujourd'hui
le virus est partout en france
donc il n'ya pas de réserves cachées
aujourd'hui nos soignants sont très
fatigués à juste titre parce qu'ils ont
été au front pour la première vague
ils ont ensuite dû re programmer tous
les autres soins durant tout l'été et il
ya cette deuxième vague et donc nous
n'avons pas de lit en réserve de les
cacher et donc c'est pour ça que nous
devons prendre des mesures plus strictes
pour justement reprendre pleinement le
contrôle pour reprendre votre formule on
reviendra dans un instant sur la
situation de délit de réanimation les
français ont vécu de longues semaines de
confinement et face à cette vague qui
semble inexorable et qui monte vous
aviez plusieurs options recombiner tout
le pays recombiner comme l'ont fait
certains voisins européens une vie d'une
agglomération ou instaurer un ou des
couvre-feux il se dit depuis plusieurs
jours que vous avez opté pour cette
option là le couvre-feu est ce que c'est
le cas oui mais j'aide un mot vous
expliquer d'abord pourquoi on agit tout
c'est pourquoi on fait ça on l'a dit si
on doit réagir c'est qu'on doit freiner
la diffusion du virus
d'abord pour protéger les autres parfois
nous mêmes ça dépend dont on parle mais
les plus âgées les plus vulnérables les
plus précaires premier objectif
deuxièmement on doit protéger notre
système de santé nos soignants et puis
ensuite je parle pour chacun de nos
concitoyens qui nous écoutent ce soir
parce que on a entendu ces dernières
semaines parfois certains dire moi je ne
suis pas concerné non ne m'enlevez pas
ma liberté
si j'ai le droit d'être contaminés c'est
pas vrai parce que nous sommes une
nation de citoyens on est tous liés les
uns les autres et donc même si je ne
veux pas être altruiste freiner le virus
c'est aussi protéger massants
parce que si je ne le freine pas demain
si j'ai autre chose ma mère mon père ma
soeur à autre chose il n'y aura plus de
place pour le soigner je protège mon
emploi en faisant ça donc ça c'est notre
objectif et cet objectif de manière très
concrète c'est freiner le virus c'est
faire que ces vingt mille nouveaux cas
par jour
on va devoir les ramener à 3 5000 cas
par jour parce que là on peut maîtriser
c'est que ces 200 entrées en réanimation
doit aussi fortement les réduire pour au
fond revenir à un niveau de nombre de
cas qu vide en réanimation qui est de
l'ordre de 10 à 15% d'honorer à au
maximum parce que là c'est soutenable
donc vous avez très bien dit face à ça
il serait disproportionné de re confiner
le pays notre objectif ça doit être de
réduire les contacts privés qui sont les
contacts les plus dangereux c'est à dire
les moments un peu de relâchement on va
se retrouver avec des gens qui ne sont
pas dans notre cellule familiale et où
on va c'est ce qui est souvent des
moments de convivialité il faut bien le
dire c'est ça qui est cruel dans cette
la gestion de cette maladie des moments
on risque de s'infecter parce qu'on va
être être trop proches les uns des
autres
pendant une certaine durée et donc oui
le ce qu'on appelle le couvre-feu est
une mesure qui est pertinente
on en a vu la pertinence très
concrètement en guyane c'est ce qu'on a
fait en guyane ça a permis de ralentir
les choses mais le ralentissement des
contacts sociaux
c'est ce qui nous a permis d'être
efficace en mayenne c'est ce qui nous a
permis d'être efficace en guadeloupe qui
a été très durement touché et qui a
réussi qui est en train de réussir à
réduire justement la circulation du
virus et donc la décision que nous avons
prise
c'est en effet un couvre-feu un
couvre-feu qui va s'appliquer à la
région ile de france où le virus circule
très activement et à plusieurs
métropoles à huit métropoles en plus de
la région ile de france
je les cite pour que ce soit clair pour
tout le monde
les métropoles je dis bien de grenoble
lille lyon aix marseille montpellier
rouen saint-etienne et toulouse les
l'ensemble des élus de ces métropoles
ont été appelés les préfet mobilisés
pour organiser les choses
ce couvre-feu il se fera entre 21h et 6h
du matin
et il commencera à partir de ce samedi 0
heure combien de temps écoutez il durera
le gouvernement est en mesure de le
décider pour quatre semaines
nous irons devant le parlement pour
pouvoir essayer de le prolonger jusqu'au
1er décembre
l'analyse que nous faisons c'est que si
dans les six prochaines semaines
nous arrivons dans ces zones de
circulation active à avoir les mesures
qui ont été annoncées ces dernières
semaines parce que toutes ces métropoles
ont été pour certaines à l'exception de
rouen il ya une accélération ces
derniers jours ont déjà vu leur bar être
fermées et d'autres lieux déjà subir des
contraintes si pendant six semaines
nous tenons ce couvre-feu on est
collectivement responsables justement de
d'un engagement collectif de réduction
de ses contacts à ce moment là nous
pensons que nous pourrons
progressivement réouvrir je suis très
prudent parce que l'expérience nous
enseigne qu'on ne maîtrise pas tout
qu'on ne sait pas tout dire mais six
semaines c'est le temps qui nous paraît
utile je bien simplement que l'on
comprenne l'objectif l'objectif c'est de
pouvoir continuer à avoir une vie
économique a fonctionné à travailler à
ce que les écoles les lycées les
universités soit ouverte et fonctionne à
ce que nos concitoyens puissent
travailler tout à fait normalement à ce
qu'il puisse y avoir évidemment une vie
sociale mais en réduire des aspérités et
au fond ce qu'on veut surtout attrapé si
j'ose dire
à travers cette mesure de couvre feu
c'est tout ce qui a fait progresser le
virus dans ces régions c'est à dire les
rendez vous entre guillemets privé les
les parties les les anniversaires les
moments de convivialité on se retrouvait
à 50 et 60 des soirées festives
malheureusement parce que ce sont des
vecteurs d'accélération de ce virus pour
être clair et oui prêt à 21h dans toutes
ces villes
ça doit faire 18 20 millions d'habitants
j'ai fait la division l'an prochain a
dit que vous avez raison tous les
cinémas tous les théâtres tous les
restaurants tous les bars sont des rides
tout le monde est chez soi ou sur le
chemin du retour vers chez soi alors les
ils fermeront en effet pour cette heure
après ça dépend
je pense qu'il faut accompagner de
beaucoup de bon sens tout cela est d'une
gestion très local c'est à dire que
évidemment tous tous ces établissements
se devront fermer à 21h54 nation
particulière si vous habitez à côté du
restaurant vous pouvez sortir à 21h être
chez vous si vous avez une demi heure de
transport vous allez vous organiser pour
le pour le quitter à 20h30
et puis après il y aura aussi des
éléments de concertation locale parce
qu'on voit bien que les situations sont
très différentes
l'organisation nos vies ne sont pas les
mêmes à grenoble rouen saint-etienne ou
paris 21h c'est important parce qu'il ya
double conséquence évidemment sur les
restaurants sur les barres déjà très
affectée par les précédents de mesures
sur les théâtres sur les salles de
spectacle est ce que vous avez prévu de
nouveaux dispositifs pour venir en aide
à ces commerces alors vous avez d'avoir
totalement raison on va essayer d'aider
au maximum
par exemple pour les théâtres les
cinémas à pouvoir avoir des
reprogrammations organiser les choses
pour pouvoir y aller un peu plus tôt je
le dis parce que dans beaucoup
d'établissements les restaurants les
théâtres les cinémas
on a conçue collectivement des règles
qui font qu'on est très bien protégé
très bien protégé parce qu'on a réduit
le nombre de personnes avec qui on est à
table au restaurant parce qu'on a des
protocoles aujourd'hui sanitaires qui
sont très efficaces au cinéma comme au
théâtre ou à l'opéra autres et donc là
dessus on va essayer de programmer un
peu plus tôt il est sûr qu'il y aura des
conséquences économiques pour ces
secteurs
il reste en trois tiers des dons et donc
de manière très claire par exemple à
paris c'est très bien que si on fait si
on demande ce couvre-feu à 21h on a même
des restaurants qui décideront de fermer
donc je vais être très clair pendant 1,5
même d'abord on y reviendra sans doute
quand on parlera d'économies mais le
chômage partiel à plein c'est à dire 100
% par l'employé pour l'employeur va être
réactivée pour tous ces secteurs
hôtellerie cafés restaurants tourisme
événementiel culture sport donc 100% 84%
jusqu'à 80 jusqu'à 4,5 smic à 84% du net
pour les salariés mais on prend en
charge à 100% pour l'employeur on a
donné des délais nouveau pour les prêts
garantis par l'état
on peut décaler d'un an le début du
remboursement et on l'est on l'a
échelonné sur cinq ans avec des taux
très préférentiels qui on était
négocier et on pourra demander les
tranches supplémentaires auxquels on a
droit et puis dès vendredi dans chacune
de ces métropoles
on va relancer une concertation locale
avec tous les métiers qui sont concernés
et nous allons améliorer la réponse
économique avec tous ces professionnels
je le dis je pense en particulier à nos
restaurateurs ils ont fait des efforts
extraordinaires ils portent l'art de
vivre à la française
et c'est vrai que dans certains endroits
ils n'auront plus intérêt à fermer où
ils devront fermer parce que leurs
charges fixes sont trop importantes
comment améliorer notamment la reine ça
veut dire que très concrètement on va
mettre en place des dispositifs
supplémentaires parce que de manière
très claire je ne veux pas que nos
indépendant nos tpe nos pme ferme
tombent en faillite à cause de ce
couvre-feu comme c'était à cause du
confinement la vie économique fait que
dans certains secteurs on sait les
conséquences qu'on a on le voit
aujourd'hui avec certains cas dont on
parle à juste titre beaucoup mais nous
nous aurons des dispositifs de soutien
supplémentaire c'est à dire qu'on va
améliorer l'accompagnement économique de
tous ces secteurs dans les métropoles où
le couvre-feu est installé parce que
pour certains il faudra faire plus que
ce qu'on a fait avec le fonds pour les
indépendants ou avec les mécanismes que
je viens de dire
je rajoute un point pour les
indépendants je le rappelle on l'a
étendu jusqu'à 50 salariés le mécanisme
on prend jusqu'à 60% du chiffre
d'affaires et jusqu'à 10000 euros
donc ça c'est france entière on va
devoir améliorer ce dispositif dans les
métropoles
aujourd'hui un restaurateur à paris qui
a des loyers important qui a fait tous
les efforts pour se conformer
s'il ne s'en sort pas en fermant à 21h
il accompagnera jouer qu'on revienne
très concrètement aux restrictions de
libertés individuelles qui vont nous
être où elle imposée et va-t-il y avoir
des exemptions des exceptions j'ai
compris que je ne pourrais pas me
promener à 22h15 sans motif valable
gratte il des attestations comme pendant
le confinement y aura-t-il des
applications sur téléphone portable
commence à face oui exactement comme
cela est à dire dès samedi matin et dès
samedi donc c'est le travail qui sera
fait dans les deux jaguars dma sion dès
demain le premier ministre avec les
ministres une conférence de presse pour
rentrer dans les détails mais de manière
très simple je les dis nous allons
continuer à travailler notre économie en
a besoin
notre société en a besoin on en a besoin
nos enfants ont besoin de continuer
d'être à l'école je me félicite que nous
ayons été parmi les premiers pays à
rouvrir nos classes qu'on ait réussi la
rentrée scolaire et je remercie nos
enseignants qui ont fait un travail
formidable
on doit continuer ça on doit continuer
de pouvoir aller au travail dans tous
les secteurs se soigner pour faire
tourner notre industrie nos services et
notre pays a besoin de sa morale et puis
pour pour financer le reste du modèle
est donc évidemment pour toutes celles
et ceux qui rentrent du travail après
21h ou qui travaillent de nuit qui
travaillent plus tard il y aura une
autorisation pour celles et ceux qui ont
des urgences par exemple sanitaires il y
aura des autorisations
donc on va définir les cas là aussi je
dirais de bon sens qui permettront de
circuler
il n'y aura pas une interdiction de
circuler entre 21h et 6h du matin il y
aura une stricte limitation aux bonnes
raisons et ça veut dire par contre que
on ira plus restaurant en sortira plus
du restaurant après 21h qu'on ira plus
chez des amis qu'on n'ira plus faire la
fête parce qu'on sait que c'est là qu'on
se contaminent plus facilement et qu'il
faut réduire et qui fera respecter le
couvre-feu et skhira la police est ce
qu'il y aura des militaires je pense à
la clinique contre avis oui il y aura
des mesures ad d'abord il y aura des
contrôles et je remercie nos forces de
l'ordre de le faire depuis le début et
il y aura des amendes comme il y en a
déjà pour justement beaucoup
d'infractions prévues
donc ce sera une amende de 135 euros qui
est celle qui prévaut pour aujourd'hui
les masques ou les restrictions déjà
quand il y en a qui sont observés je le
rappelle et je rappelle aussi que en cas
de récidive ces 1500 euros parce que
c'est il faut jamais l'oublier ça doit
être dissuasif et on va mobiliser tous
nos policiers et donc on va mobiliser de
manière proportionnée et ça aussi ce
sera fait localement pour le faire mais
ce que j'espère aussi ce que j'attends
de chacun d'entre nous sait que comme on
l'a fait au moment de confinement chacun
soit conscient des risques et de l'enjeu
vous savez au moment du confinement nous
avons été l'une des nations qui a le
mieux respecter cette décision
elle était très difficile les français
ont été exemplaires parce qu il
compris que c'était pour protéger les
plus fragiles pour protéger nos
soignants et nous l'avons respecté
beaucoup mieux que dans d'autres pays
les chiffres le montrent le rapport
d'évaluation que j'évoquais le dis très
clairement et donc moi ce que j'attends
de chacune et chacun d'entre nous sait
que dans les zones où c'est décidé on le
fait à à bon droit
parce qu'il ya des chiffres qui sont
transparents que ont partagé qui sont là
on en a besoin et si on ne veut pas
devoir prendre dans quinze jours trois
semaines un mois des mesures plus dures
il faut le faire et de respecter et donc
moi je je crois encore plus à la
responsabilité de chaque citoyen mais
bien évidemment il y aura des contrôles
et pourtant le rapport que vous évoquez
il parle aussi d'infantilisation ils
vous reprochent une certaine
infantilisation ça que le couple nous
essayons aussi ça nous essayons
collectivement nous améliorer je pense
que nous devons tous et je pense qu'on y
reviendra pour la france entière et
c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire ces
dernières semaines nous sommes tous en
quelque sorte les acteurs de cette
bataille contre le virus et de notre
réussite
il ya certains endroits si on veut être
aller beaucoup plus vite être plus
radicaux on a besoin de règles communes
et ça c'est mettre des règles c'est pas
infantiliser c'est juste de dire à des
citoyennes et des citoyens responsables
voilà mais des règles parce qu on a
besoin collectivement de s'est fixé
parce que sinon on a on n'agira pas
assez fortement et je le redis tous nos
voisins le fond et des voisins qui sont
aujourd'hui en allemagne il doit y avoir
six ou sept mille cas par jour on est à
vingt mille l'allemagne prend des
mesures de ce type aujourd'hui présentée
est la moins deux morts au 6 mai donc ça
veut dire et ne parlent pas
d'infantilisation donc je ne pense pas
que nous prenions des mesures qui sont
disproportionnées je pense qu'on prend
des mesures qui sont proportionnées au
regard du risque qu'on voit après le
rapport d'évaluation montre aussi que
quand on se compare la france en
mortalité a bien tenu les choses parce
que si on regarde sur deux trois ans les
comparaisons qu'on a parfois fait entre
la france et l'allemagne non ce ne sont
pas si vrai qu'on le croit encore une
question très pratique il y aura dans
ces villes dans ces agglomérations sous
couvre feu
autant de transports en commun je
pourrais prendre un train de l'île à
paris qui arrive à paris à 22h15 et
rentrer en taxi autant de vtc alors dire
on vous allez mettre un peu le l'offre
de transport en commun
elle sera évidemment mobilisé comme
d'ailleurs nous l'avions fait aussi même
s'il y avait un petit peu de réduction
confinement mais elle continuera d'être
mobilisés y aura pas de restriction des
transports
premier point c'est important parce
qu'il ya des gens qui continueront à
travailler la nuit ou en soirée ou le
matin tôt et parce qu'il doit y avoir
des déplacements pour des bonnes raisons
ensuite nous n'avons pas décidé de
réduire les déplacements entre les
régions
là aussi c'est un choix parce que je
pense que comme vous l'avez dit le choix
de ne pas infantiliser mais de
responsabiliser et donc ça veut dire
qu'on n'empêche pas les gens de passer
d'une région à l'autre
outre est d'ailleurs concrètement de
partir en vacances mais on va leur
demander de respecter des règles de
citoyenneté
pendant les semaines et les mois qui
viennent ça certains vont avoir du mal à
le comprendre parce que ces vacances de
la toussaint c'est le moment des
rassemblements familiaux les plus jeunes
vous retrouvez sans doute des grands
parents est-ce qu'il ya pas un danger
justement à permettre ces vacances a
incité même à prendre ses vacances de la
toussaint c'est ce qu'a fait le
secrétaire d'état au tourisme
alors qu'on est en pleine crise alors
que certains enfants viendront aussi de
régions de métropole où effectivement
l'épidémie est un très haut niveau
on sait que quand on est dans des
espaces qui sont ouverts on peut prendre
l'air on sait que quand on est justement
dans des lieux où on peut sortir on
lutte plus efficacement contre le virus
donc demandé aux gens de rester chez eux
dans un appartement et de ne pas aller
dans un lieu de vacances
honnêtement ce serait disproportionné
parfois contre intuitif qu'en fait on va
soulager un peu les métropoles en
permettant aussi pour partie est
d'ailleurs d'aller regarder c'est un peu
ce qu'on avait vécu au début du
confinement est ce que pour autant on a
eu du virus qui s'est mis partout non
par contre ce qu'on va dire très
clairement ce que je dis ce soir très
clairement à nos concitoyens
s'ils vont dans une location dans leur
maison de vacances c'est de respecter
les règles comme si ils étaient chez eux
c'est à dire de continuer à prendre
évidemment les précautions qui va y
avoir partout dans la société mais
surtout si on va se rassembler en
famille et là aussi c'est encore une
fois du bon sens je partage la
contrainte avec vous tous et toutes
c'est que on va pas réglementé tous les
comportements je vais pas dire aux gens
on vous empêche de bouger de votre ville
on vous empêche trois jours avant de
partir en vacances là vous me diriez
vous infantiliser les gens non vous
pouvez partir en vacances parce que ce
serait disproportionné de vous empêcher
de le faire mais si vous allez en
famille si vous allez avec les grands
parents
si vous allez avec des membres de votre
famille qui sont fragiles il est
impératif de respecter les règles
d'usagé c'est-à-dire même dans le cadre
familial de mettre vos masques si vous
ne venez pas d'être testé et eux non
plus c'est à dire de protéger les autres
cantons mais son masque on protège les
autres et donc de mettre vos masques
quand vous êtes à moins d'un mètre de
garder au maximum les distances et les
promenades dehors pour s'aérer c'est une
très bonne chose mais se confiner à voir
des gestes même d'affection si je puis
dire sans aucune précaution n'est pas
adapté à la période que nous vivons
n'est réalisé le port du masque dans des
départements des régions le 6 ou le
virus circule peut alors si vous voulez
on prend deux pas de recul là on vient
de dire ce que nous allons faire sous
réserve de vote du parlement dans les
six semaines à venir dans les endroits
où le virus circule le plus activement
et donc ces fameux couvre feu avec
l'accompagnement économique
exceptionnelle et le soutien et en
continuant à travailler à venir et je le
dis c'est très important j'insiste là
dessus
le travail va continuer dans toutes ces
métropoles ces régions les associations
vont continuer de fonctionner pour
s'occuper des plus précaires les
services publics vont continuer à
fonctionner cet indispensable dans le
reste du pays qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
nous devons si je puis dire nous
remobiliser collectivement je sais qu'il
ya beaucoup d'efforts qui ont été faits
par nos concitoyens mais je veux ici
dire les règles qu'on va appliquer
partout ces règles
ce sont des gestes simples il faut les
garder dans l'enceinte familiale et
partout en france
garder des distances plus d'un mètre
évidemment avec son conjoint 7 et ceux
avec qui on vit toute la semaine et en
permanence il ya une proximité qui est
là mais quand on est avec d'autres
membres de la famille des amis ou autres
garder cette distance d'un mètre se
laver régulièrement les mains avec un
gel hydroalcoolique où le ca vous porter
au maximum un masque il y à des endroits
où c'est obligatoire je reviens pas sur
ces règles elles ce sont 1
allez maintenant localement il faut pas
les changer par contre au maximum quand
on est un intérieur qu'on ne peut pas
respecter ces règles
même dans des réunions privées il faut
mettre au masque au maximum ce masque
c'est une forme de discipline de réflexe
qu'on doit prendre
c'est une recommandation que je fais là
mais si on veut être précautionneux
réduire le risque pour soi et les autres
il vaut mieux le prendre y compris en
famille ou avec des amis
4e règle aussi pour tout le monde france
entière aérer régulièrement il faut
aérer les scientifiques nous disent dix
minutes trois fois par jour mais aéré de
manière régulière il ya des protocoles
qui sont fait d'ailleurs dans les écoles
comme chez les professionnels de santé
c'est important
et puis dernière règle je dis ça parce
qu'on a regardé ce qui marche et chez
nos voisins cette fameuse règle des six
au restaurant on l'a dit et je remercie
une fois encore nos restaurateurs on a
dit pas plus de 6 à table et bien au
maximum pour notre vie personnelle
il faut qu'on fasse ça si on a une
famille de 7 8 9 10 évident continue à
avoir une vie familiale normale la
hausse il faut avoir du bon sens et pas
plus de 6 dans les urnes on essaie on
essaie quand on invite des amis de ne
pas être plus de 6 à table et pas plus
de 6 dans la rue non plus on est à mes
yeux ne pas se regrouper voilà plus de
six est réglée si ce qui est une règle
de bon sens que chacun peut avoir faut
essayer de se l'appliquer à soi-même
parce que c'est aussi quelque chose qui
nous protège et qui va un peu qui va
nous aider à freiner france entière tout
cela est donc voyez partout sur le
territoire
ces règles ne relève pas je rejoins ce
que vous disiez et qui est en effet un
des enseignements c'est pas des règles
qu'on va mettre dans des décors et des
protocoles par tous ces des règles dont
je voudrais que chaque citoyenne et
citoyen se les approprient pleinement
est-ce que ses réflexes ils ont compris
les jeunes parce que je parle des jeunes
parce que on a l'impression quand même
que le couvre-feu vise aussi une
population jeune qui sort qui fait la
fête qui a beaucoup d'internés mais
enfin est-ce que c'est dur c'est dur
d'avoir 20 en 2020 c'est dur donc je
donnerais jamais de leçon à nos jeunes
est ce que ce sont ceux qui honnêtement
vivent un sacrifice terrible des examens
annulé de l' angoisse pour les
formations de l' angoisse pour trouver
le premier job c'est aussi pour ça qu'on
a mis une telle mobilisation un jeune
une solution je rappelle que nous avons
créé des nouvelles formations
on a justement réouvert des places pour
que des jeunes puissent rester refaire
des formations en faculté comme en cfa
comme dans des écoles post bac on à
développer l'apprentissage massivement
en accompagnant les entreprises pour
qu'elles puissent leur donner des places
en apprentissage et des chiffres se
tiennent à peu près dans cette rentrée
et donc en payant beaucoup plus en
compensant l'employeur pour que les
jeunes puissent trouver leur place donc
on fera tout pour nos jeunes mais c'est
normal quand on est jeune on fait la
fête on a des amis et donc je
culpabiliserai personnes non mais je
voudrais que comprennent pendant
quelques semaines et quelques mois que
je n'en ai pas d'avoir moins d'amis on
va devoir faire un peu d'effort c'est à
dire se voir moins nombreux en même
temps et essayer aussi de d'avoir cette
règle de se protéger les uns les autres
et donc je sais que c'est un effort
énorme mais au fond le pari que nous
faisons maintenant c'est je partage avec
vous toutes les informations que j'ai la
contrainte
il y a des des zones ces fameuses
métropole la région ile de france ça va
tellement vite qu'on a besoin de prendre
ce couvre-feu qui va être dur pour des
secteurs économiques est qui et qui
contraignant je le mesure pour le reste
du pays plus chacune et chacun porte ces
règles plus on arrivera ensemble à
freiner il ya autre chose
je vais demander aussi dans la france
entière de à l'ensemble des élus à nos
mères de nous proposer des plans de
prévention
les maires en associant mieux les
citoyens ils le font formidablement ils
ont des des conseils de citoyens ils ont
créé leur propre structure
on a besoin d'associer pleinement nos
citoyens et d'associer nos élus les
maires doivent aussi être dans cette
phase des acteurs de la prévention
ils sont ce sont ceux qui savent le
mieux aller chercher nos aînés aller
chercher des associations pour expliquer
porter nos messages mieux protégés donc
voilà ce qu'on va faire après france
entière en continuant à limiter aussi
les grands rassemblements et continuant
les règles qu'on a depuis la rentrée
vous même et vos ministres vous dites
depuis quelques jours quelques semaines
que la règle dorénavant sans qu'on sache
jusqu'où cette règle nous mène
c'est le télétravail pour le plus grand
nombre possible
à quel étiage 50% du temps alors 80%
d'environ 1%
et puis il ya le privé sur lequel vous
n'avez pas le droit directement
intervenir et la fonction publique
qu'est ce que vous dites aux cinq
millions et demi de fonctionnaires
restez chez vous le plus possible non je
vais pas dire ça comme ça parce que
d'abord travaillé que ce soit en
entreprise dans un service public dans
une collectivité locale ou aux services
de l'état dans une association c'est un
collectif et je pense qu'il faut faire
attention le télétravail c'est un outil
quand on utilise intelligemment que
c'est flexible que ça que c'est presque
individualisé négocier au plus près
c'est intelligent si c'est une règle
nationale
là maintenant on a dû le faire au moment
du confinement mais là maintenant
parfois on ré isole les gens savaient le
télétravail
je vais être un peu direct quand on a
une résidence secondaire tout à fait
sympathique et comptent aider travail
c'est chouette quand on a un appartement
que les enfants sont à la maison qu'on a
la promiscuité
ça devient vite très dur et puis on a
besoin d'échanger avec des collègues de
travail donc il faut là aussi du bon
sens on a besoin que les entreprises
fonctionnent elles ont besoin d'avoir du
de la présence au travail
on a besoin d'avoir des services publics
qui soit ouvert des bureaux de poste
qu'ils soient tous ouverts ils m'ont pas
rose non pas du tout gosse les paras du
tube qui ont fermé en avril
on a besoin d'avoir des professeurs qui
sont en classe et c'est donc oui faut
que tout le monde soit présent au
maximum mais là où c'est possible quand
on est dans un bureau il n'y a pas
d'accès au public
quand on est dans une entreprise où les
règles peuvent le faire dans la mesure
du possible et négocier au plus près du
terrain
on va plutôt inciter les gens à faire
pour les emplois ou housse et pertinents
deux à trois jours de télétravail par
semaine c'est ce que font certains
depuis plusieurs semaines pourquoi parce
que ça réduit un peu la pression
collective et la circulation mais voilà
faut du bon sens mais ça n'est pas la
panacée faut aussi que ce soit négocier
et je les partenaires sociaux ont raison
d'insister là dessus
négocié dans les branches et au plus
près de l'entreprise il faut jamais
oublier que on vit ensemble et je pense
que il faut qu'on réussisse à réduire
nos contacts un peu inutiles parfois nos
contacts pardon de le dire comme ça mais
les plus festifs mais qu'on continue à
avoir une vie sociale au travail on
s'est bien se protéger parce qu'on a
maintenant la règle du masque à l'école
au lycée à l'université
dans les associations parce que c'est
c'est la vie on aussi on a l'impression
que la situation que vous avez des
critiques qui nous amène à imposer ce
couvre-feu dans les métropoles
elle était prévisible elle était même
prévu prévu par les avis du conseil
scientifique en juin en juillet il
parlait d'ailleurs de la pression sur
ces métropoles sur le danger que le
virus soit plus virulent à la rentrée
cela était prévisible
et puis il ya eu l'échec de la politique
de dépistage
d'abord on a attendu longtemps c'était
ce temps les a entendus nous attendions
mais en juin en juillet ça commence à
arriver
et puis après on n'arrive pas à
comprendre comment on a pu prévoir
l'amour c'est à dire tout le temps et
pas l'aval c'est-à-dire pas l'examen
c'est à ce pape a les moyens pour pour
traiter ces tests au moins deux jours
parce que au-delà de jours c'était
l'argent jeté par les fenêtres alors
vous avez raison on a rencontré des
vraies difficultés sur ce sujet je crois
qu'il faut le dire et les partager
pourquoi parce que on a monté on s'était
donné des moyens et on a plutôt suivi la
trajectoire des moyens qu'on s'était
donné on est aujourd'hui l'un des pays
qui testent plus en europe
pas forcément le plus efficacement mais
je vais revenir pour moi parce que ça
c'est les techniques de test mais on
fait entre 1,2 et 1,4 million et quand
je regarde ces derniers jours parce que
vous comprendrez bien que je le
surveille quotidiennement avec les
ministres et je veux ici vraiment rendre
hommage au travail du gouvernement
mobilisation du premier ministre au
ministre de la santé qui jour et nuit
fait son maximum avec ses équipes pour
faire les difficultés qu'on a eu c'est
qu'il ya eu beaucoup de demandes
beaucoup plus qu'on ne pensait pas ce
que c'était gratuit
oui mais à ce qu'il vous la politique de
la polémique qu'on a eu à la rentrée sur
les masques et ce qu'il fallait que ce
soit gratuit ou pas à l'école on l'a
rendu gratuit pour tous les enfants de
familles modestes les plus précaires des
millions parce que c'était pas gratuit
pour tout le monde on a eu des
polémiques
vous pensez que la solution c'était de
rendre payant le test moi je crois pas
non ces deux prêts dont les noyangevins
elioth allemand j'assume totalement
qu'on est en effet rendu le test gratuit
parce qu'on a décidé nous en france qui
aurait pas de barrière à l'argent faut
le dire et depuis le début de cette
crise c'est ce qu'on a fait on est l'un
des pays qui a le plus accompagné
économiquement et socialement
notre nation et je les assume et c'est
de cette égratignant anticipé cette
vague parce que c'était gratuit
peut-être mais moi je crois pas qu'ils
aient beaucoup de gens qui est exquis et
à l'excès et et se faire tester c'est
parce que c'était surtout il y avait de
l'inquiétude parce que le virus a
circulé c'est tout parce que le virus a
circulé entre les générations et on le
voit un peu partout en europe
donc je ne mettrai pas ça sur le compte
de la politique de test je dis juste que
ce que décrit très bien le rapport
on a en effet eu des délais qui étaient
trop longs pourquoi parce qu'on n'avait
pas l'organisation qui permettait de le
faire je remercie mois l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé publics et
privés qui se sont mobilisés mais on
n'avait pas de grosses centrales de test
on a un réseau qui est en plein de
petits points et donc on avait un
système qui était pas habitué à faire
avoir une telle pression et donc il y
avait de la queue pour obtenir le test
de la queue pour avoir les résultats et
ça c'est lié à la technique vous
entendez beaucoup parlé de ce test on
appelle pcr en effet font une technique
d'analysé alors comment on va répondre à
ça on va changer les choses et je veux
aussi donner une perspective à nos
concitoyens la jeudi pour six semaines
on va faire couvre-feu dans ces
métropoles en régions île de france et
on se remobilise partout dans le pays
pourrait essayer de gagner cette
bataille
ensuite on doit progressivement aller
vers une stratégie qui est partout dans
notre pays
testez alerte et protégés c'est la clé
de la stratégie qu'on doit faire monter
en puissance tout le mois de novembre et
en décembre
parce que nous en avons jusqu'à l'été
2021 au moins avec ce virus tous les
scientifiques sont claires et donc si on
ne veut pas faire tout le temps des
déblocages redémarrage il faut qu'on
arrive au fond à beaucoup mieux suivre
ce virus pour ça que je vous dis qu
il faut qu'on réussisse à baisser le
nombre de contaminations jours plus tôt
à 3000 5000 cas qu'à 20 milles comme on
est aujourd'hui est donc premier pilier
testé on a une innovation qui est arrivé
ces derniers jours reconnue par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé la
haute autorité de santé
ce sont ce qu'on appelle ces tests
antigénique il va toujours falloir faire
ce fameux prélèvement ou dans le nez ou
la bouche avec sa fameuse écouvillon
tout le monde est devenu expert de
sujets mais c'est en 15 à 30 minutes
qu'on a le résultat change beaucoup de
choses on pourra aussi le faire dans les
pharmacies dans différents points donc
ça on aura plus de point d'appui pas
simplement dans des laboratoires ça ça
va être un vrai changement
ensuite on développe des techniques pour
analyser beaucoup plus vite plus de
tests ensemble avec le mode pcr et puis
on continue à innover pas qu'en france
partout dans le monde pour aller vers
des autotests ou sur la base de votre
salive parfois de votre sang vous
pourrez vous auto testé on est habitué à
le faire et que les tests de grossesse
ou d'autres tests et donc nous allons
rentrer dans une stratégie on va
déployer là pendant les prochaines
semaines où on va pouvoir réduire encore
drastiquement les délais et donc dès
qu'on a une hésitation qu'on est qu'à
contacter qu'on est symptomatique ou
qu'on a un doute on pourra se faire
tester on aura la réponse rapidement 2e
pilier l' alerte quand je suis testé il
faut que je puisse alerter
ce qu'on appelle mais qu'à contacter les
gens avec qui j'ai été exposé à moins
d'un mètre avec qui j'ai dîné avec qui
j'ai passé un long moment avec qui
j'étais à la cafétéria ou autre ce que
stop coville n'a jamais permis de faire
vous avez raison c'était un échec
cuisant
alors les derniers chiffres vous avez un
peu vide a servi à alerter à ce jour
493 alors c'est je prendrais pas ce
chiffre pour dire que c'est un échec
ça n'a pas marché c'est à dire que c'est
surtout ça a été beaucoup moins
téléchargées de tous nos voisins
deux millions et demi de personnes à peu
près les britanniques les allemands ont
beaucoup plus de téléchargements
on n'a pas réussi mais quand je regarde
nos voisins aujourd'hui et les cas qui
ont été identifiés par une telle
application même en allemagne en
angleterre très peu donc personne n'a
réussi à faire de l'application un vrai
outil d' alerte
mais nous à ce stade on n'a pas réussi à
faire de l'application un outil pour les
gens donc depuis plusieurs semaines j'ai
demandé aux équipes de complètement
reconfiguré les choses faut qu'on ait
une nouvelle application elle va
s'appeler tous antico vide chacun est
mobilisée c'est une application et loire
garder ce qui marche et des autres
apprendre de nos erreurs
c'est pour quand le 22 octobre elle sera
présente et elle va comme sa montée en
charge
ce sera une application d'abord où il y
aura des informations comment virus
circule le virus pardon là où vous êtes
où sont les points pour se faire tester
et suivre un peu voka donc y aura des
informations générales des informations
plus particulière et locales parce que
les gens vont plus souvent consultés
l'application quand il ya ça ce que font
très bien les britanniques
ensuite on va donner aussi un mode
d'emploi ça sert à rien de l'allumer
tout le temps beaucoup de gens ont dit
sa vie de ma batterie je sais même plus
comment le je suis pas sûr du tout ça
marche pas et c'est on va donner un mode
d'emploi très clair on va dire aux gens
quand vous allez au restaurant quand
vous allez dès qu'on pourra les réouvrir
dans les zones concernées au bar quand
vous allez chez des amis au fond à
chaque fois que je suis dans un moment
où je suis exposé à d'autres gens qui
vont pas avoir de masse où il ya un
élément de risque on allume le justement
le tout sans tics au vide et on va en
faire aussi un instrument avec nos
restaurateurs avec l'ensemble des
cafetiers avec les hôtels avec tous les
professionnels un outil pour mieux
alerter tracé et donc du coup pour
identifier ces foyers de contamination
les remonter et prévenir et puis
troisième chose faut protéger en étant
très stricte sur les sept jours
d'isolement quand on a le virus
même quand on n'a pas de symptômes et
adapté justement là-dessus notre réponse
est donc ça c'est la stratégie vers
laquelle on va mettre beaucoup plus de
moyens pour réussir
dès qu'on aura moins de cas par jour à
ce qu' il y ait moins de contraintes
collectives mais qu'on suive mieux ce
virus et on le maîtrise mieux l'un des
enseignements de cette sanitaire sait
que statistiquement ce sont les plus
défavorisés qui ont été le plus victime
des victimes sanitaire des victimes
économiques également
certaines associations certaines
associations caritatives
le responsable aussi de la cfdt demande
l'augmentation des minima sociaux du rsa
et demande également que les 18 25 ans
puisse bénéficier du rsa est ce que vous
dites oui alors on va apporter une
réponse à cela d'ailleurs comme nous
l'avions fait au printemps
d'abord c'est tout à fait vrai que sur
le plan sanitaire
je le disais tout à l'heure le virus
frappe davantage les milieux modestes
parce qu'on vit dans des appartements
plus petits
parce que souvent on vit entre
générations beaucoup plus que quand on a
les moyens d'avoir un appartement
voilà des cons et ados ou adultes
la deuxième chose c'est que sur le plan
économique et social
cette crise elle est aussi inégalitaire
pourquoi parce que les emplois qui ont
été détruits ce sont surtout les emplois
en cdd et en intérim
c'est à dire des plus précaires et donc
c'est aussi pour ça que j'assume la
force de la réponse économique que nous
avons eu hélas rapport aussi dit très
clairement nous sommes sans doute le
pays d'europe qui a été le plus fort sur
ce sujet qui a le plus investi 460
milliards d'euros et nous allons
continuer de le faire comme je les dis
de manière exceptionnelle mais en effet
les plus précaires qui tombent dans la
pauvreté on doit avoir une réponse est
donc ce que nous allons faire parce que
c'est le dispositif le plus large et
plus efficace
c'est pour les bénéficiaires du rsa et
des apl ce qui touche du coup tous les
jeunes là aussi très largement les 18 25
ans d'avoir une aide exceptionnelle
là pendant 7 ces six semaines qui
viennent
250 euros plus 100 euros par enfant
la même chose que ce qu'on a fait
justement au printemps ce qui permettra
d'aller entre 100 et 450 euros et plus
sain qu'une revalorisation mais moi je
tiens aussi à une chose c'est qu'on ne
perde pas nos fondamentaux
nos fondamentaux c'est la lutte contre
la pauvreté par le retour à l'activité
le travail et plus on augmente de
manière unilatérale
tous nos minima sociaux on les rebelles
jamais après plus on rend difficile le
retour à l'activité
c'est ce qu'on a constaté et c'est aussi
pour ça que j'assume il ya quelques mois
d'avoir mal
si je mens et historiquement augmenter
la prime d'activité au niveau du smic
200 euros par mois
et donc je préfère cette aide
exceptionnelle massive comparable à ce
que nous avons fait au printemps plutôt
qu'une transformation de nos minima
sociaux quand on parle de minima sociaux
je veux quand même aussi ici redire que
le minimum vieillesse et de l'allocation
adultes handicapés ont depuis le début
de ce quinquennat une augmentation
historique près de 100 euros par mois
monsieur le président il voit juste
quelques instants je vais vous poser une
question qui qui tombe sous le sens
j'imagine pour de nombreux français la
description de ce que vous nous faites
de l'avenir du virus qui va durer sans
doute jusqu'à l'été prochain de
plusieurs villes 20 millions d'habitants
qui vont être un petit peu quand même
sous cloche de 21h à 6h du matin c'est
assez sombre est ce qu'il ya une raison
une raison d'espérer qu'on ait 20 ans 65
ans ou plus
il ya énormément de raisons d'espérer si
on est lucide collectif uni lucide c'est
à dire que moi je veille à ce que
l'information soit transparente et
partager je crois qu'on est le premier
pays au monde à avoir demandé un rapport
d'évaluation de la première phase il a
été rendu public
les données sanitaires on les partage
comme les données économiques tout le
temps je pense qu'il faut dans le pays
des lumières et de pasteurs qu'on arrête
d'avoir des espèces de débat permanent
sur les faits ou la vérité scientifique
il ya un conseil scientifique qui joue
un rôle essentiel il va d'ailleurs être
pérennisé je remercie ses membres mais
voilà on a quelques certitudes 62 mais
au fait est pas pas dire chaque jour
ceci n'est rien on peut faire comme ça
donc si on se base sur les faits ou peut
dire c'est grave c'est sérieux mais se
mobiliser la raison d'espérer je vais
vous dire c'est que nous sommes en train
de réapprendre à être pleinement une
nation c'est à dire qu'on s'était
progressivement habitué à être une
société d'individus libres
nous sommes une nation de citoyens
solidaires nous ne pouvons pas nous en
sortir
si chacun ne joue pas son rôle ne met
pas sa part voilà la clé et donc je le
dis très clairement le message que je
suis venu passer ce soir c'est que j'ai
besoin de chacun d'entre vous que nous
avons besoin les uns des autres pour
trouver des solutions pour inventer pour
être citoyen en respectant les règles
pour nous mêmes et pour les autres mais
surtout pour inventer et on sortira de
cela en étant une nation plus résiliente
on va continuer à surmonter nos défis on
va continuer à régler la crise
climatique et la transition climatique
mais on voit aussi et on est en train de
le faire apprendre à une nation plus
résiliente qui va produire de l'économie
de la vie sur son territoire à nouveau
on va reproduire des médicaments des
matériaux nécessaires qui réapprend à se
protéger et à surmonter cette crise
comme les autres on sortira plus fort
parce qu'on sera plus unis voilà
vraiment si j'avais un message à passer
à nos concitoyens c'est ça nous avons
besoin les uns des autres on s'en
sortira ensemble c'était le mot de la
fin
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
nous avoir reçu anne sophie mervoyer
vous et nous y arriverons nous y
arriverons très bonne soirée à tous 45
minutes d'interview chez nos confrères
de tf1 et france 2 et une annonce à
retenir ce soir de la part d' emmanuel
macron un couvre feu entre 21h le soir
et 6 heures le matin à partir de samedi
en région ile de france et dans huit
métropoles que je vais tout de suite
vous énumérez à nouveau si vous venez de
vous nous rejoindre lille rouen lyon
saint-etienne aix en provence marseille
montpellier et toulouse bonsoir à toutes
et à tous bienvenue sur figaro live on
est en direct sur lefigaro.fr bien sûr
sur twitch évidemment ainsi que sur
youtube on attend vos réactions et vos
questions suite à cet entretien entre le
chef de l'état et nos confrères de tf1
et france 2 on va débriefer ça
évidemment en direct aussi avec je vous
l'annoncé tout à l'heure marc landré
rédacteur en chef du service économie
france au figaro marc bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous alors on va activer
votre micro un marque d'ici quelques
instants l'occasion pour moi de saluer
julien à la réalisation de ce live est
de faire un clin d'oeil appuyé aussi à
julie qui réalise et bien la modération
dans les différents chat je vous le
disais sur lefigaro.fr sur twitch et sur
youtube vous êtes nombreux à nous
remercier d'avoir diffusé un cette prise
de parole du chef de l'état nombreux
aussi à nous demander si
reconfirme ans il est question eh bien
on va tout de suite posé cette question
à marc landré j'espère que le son est à
nouveau activé est ce que on peut avoir
votre première réaction marque suite à
ce qui vient de se dire du côté du chef
de l'état c'est déprimant
est-ce que selon vous c'est un sarr
confinement locales qui ne dit pas son
nom c'est vous avez 20 millions de
personnes qui vont être confiné soir
alors c'est pas un confinement sur
l'ensemble de la journée c'est pas un
confinement qui va durer six qui va
durer soixante cinq jours fin de mois et
demi on est sur 20 millions de personnes
qui n'auront pas l'autorisation qui ont
une restriction de liberté de
déplacement entre 21h et 6h le matin
donc c'est un c'est un mini confinement
pour aller 1 40% de la population
française est uniquement le soir
par contre le président de la république
a bien dit que il fallait continuer à
travailler il fallait continuer à se
déplacer pour y travailler fallait
simplement limiter les interactions
sociales faire en sorte qu'on voit moins
de gens et qu'on casse cette chaîne de
diffusion du virus à savoir de leur
défaite lors des réunions de famille
lors des dîners entre amis donc moins
enverra des gens moins on aura la
possibilité de transmettre ce satané
virus qui nous plombe tout c'est qu'il
nous empêche de vivre normalement notre
vie de citoyen français est décédé à
même chose dans les autres pays
européens d'ailleurs emmanuel macron qui
demande aussi de ne pas être plus de 6 à
table alors si vous êtes un couple avec
cinq enfants il va falloir punir un kir
à manger dans sa chambre voilà c'est un
engin de cette règle de 6 à respecter si
sa table six ans la russie son
restaurant mais il a dit s'il ya une
famille de 10 et bien évidemment on va
pas aller on va pas en mettre quatre de
côté donc il faut simplement faire
preuve de bon sens et éviter au maximum
de faire en sorte que on se retrouve à
plus de 6 ça peut être si ça peut être
sept s'est passé pas très grave cancer
d'une famille mais il faut éviter de se
démultiplier
lorsque ce n'est pas nécessaire
en tout cas vous nous poser quelques
questions d'hier dans le tchat sur
twitter notamment brad ac 38 qui nous y
bordeaux n'est pas concerné par le
couvre feu alors non bordeaux n'est pas
concernée en revanche non loin de
bordeaux à toulouse toulouse et
montpellier 1 également qu'ils sont qui
sont concernés la surprise c'était
peut-être même si emmanuel macron l'a
justifiée en expliquant que les
indicateurs n'étaient pas bons ces
derniers jours mais rouen rouen qui
arrive malheureusement dans sept ans ce
lot de vie les deux métropoles et de
régions aussi concerné par une
circulation accrue du virus
on va faire le point avec vous aussi
marc bas sur l'incidence économique de
ce qu'on vient d'entendre puisque
couvre-feu entre 21h et 6h du matin moi
j'ai une première question à vous poser
c'est est-ce que ça vaut le coup pour un
restaurateur économiquement d'ouvrir le
soir en sachant qu'il faut fermer à 21
heures maximum je pense que ça va
dépendre de chacun
ça va dépendre de la profondeur et de
l'importance des coûts fixes de chaque
restaurateur logiquement non je veux
dire à partir du moment où vous obligez
un restaurateur a fermé à 21h avant ça
pouvait être 22h notamment à marseille
j'ai pendant pendant quelques temps
c'est sûr que vous réduisez de la
capacité du restaurateur a multiplié
donc de couverts surtout qu'il faut pas
être plus de 6 à une même table qu'il
faut un espacement d'un mètre d'un
médecin quand entre chaque
entre chaque table donc plus vous plus
vous mettez des contraintes plus vous
limiter sa capacité à faire son affaire
son métier donc oui poudre dans la
grande majorité des cas les
restaurateurs ont au moins d'intérêt à
ouvrir le soir
et parce que
je pense à notamment en région
parisienne les gens vont pas aller dîner
à 18h30
ils vont pas anticipé ce qu'ils
faisaient avant pour est ressorti à 21
heures c'est trop compliqué surtout que
le président on va bien dit il faut être
à 21h chez soi donc il y aura une petite
tolérance éventuellement même s'il y
aura des contrôles et des amendes qui
seront qui seront faites il faudrait à
21h chez soi ça veut dire que pour être
à 21h chez soi en fonction de la
distance qu'il ya entre le lieu du
restaurant et son domicile il faudra
anticiper partir d'autant plus tôt et
surtout il a dit le président n'y a pas
que les restaurateurs qui sont concernés
parce que toute la vie culturelle va
être impacté les théâtres les
restaurants l'opéra les cinémas et il a
dit qu'ils allaient essayer qu'il
fallait essayer localement par des
discussions territoriale de d'anticiper
au maximum ces manifestations là où une
représentation avait lieu peut-être à
20h peut-être de l'anticiper à 18 heures
lorsqu'il va être possible dans
certaines métropoles ne sera pas
possible partout
je pense notamment à paris et que tout
ce qui va pouvoir est fait pour essayer
de limiter au maximum l'impact dans ce
monde culturelles festives du soir sera
bienvenu maintenant on se doute bien
qu'il va y avoir plus de dégâts qui va y
avoir des aménagements à une question
sur youtube vous me demandez si grenoble
est concerné par cette mesure de couvre
feu ou grenoble effectivement est
concerné c'est un oubli de ma part
grenoble tout comme dans cette région
auvergne rhône a levé bien saint-etienne
et lyon sont concernés par ce couvre-feu
qui entre en vigueur samedi à minuit
alors qui va durer quatre semaines mais
l'objectif c'est six semaines à l'heure
actuelle les dispositifs légaux ne
permettent pas de mettre en place six
semaines de couvre feu ces quatre
semaines et il va falloir aller devant
le parlement a dit emmanuel macron un
mot aussi sur les dispositifs de soutien
supplémentaires qui ont été évoquées par
le chef de l'état un marc landré
dispositif de soutien supplémentaire
qu'est ce que quel est votre votre
regard là-dessus chômage partiel à 100%
pour l'employeur dans les zones touchées
par le couvre-feu notamment oui alors il
a il les 10 pôles aux dispositifs
existants et maintenus et étendus à
toutes les professions à tous les
métiers qui vont être impactés par le
couvre feu
donc ça c'est une bonne chose sachant
que les critères ont déjà été assouplie
cette semaine pour permettre de prendre
en compte un maximum de deux situations
par exemple le fonds de solidarité va
pouvoir donner dead qui va jusqu'à 10000
euros par mois il faut savoir que
pendant la période de confinement au
printemps c'était 1500 euros donc on
voit bien qu'il ya une démultiplication
du montant de l'aide que avance au
moment du confinement c'était disponible
uniquement pour les entreprises de moins
de dix salariés
la jauge allait passer à 50 salariés
donc on prend beaucoup plus entreprises
dans les mailles du filet et que la
baisse de pouvoir dans la baisse de
chiffre d'affaires regard de laquelle on
va pouvoir demander à bénéficier du
fonds de solidarité
il faut avoir une baisse de 60% de son
chiffre d'affaires donc on voit que le
dispositif
aujourd'hui il est très large il vise à
couvrir le maximum de dégâts possibles
maintenant le président l'a dit ils
adapteront si nécessaire dans les
semaines à venir est très prochainement
pour pouvoir faire en sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas une faillite
c'est ce qu'a dit le président 1 il ne
veut pas qu'il y ait une seule faillite
à cause de ce nom pas ce confinement
mettre ce couvre feu alors il faut faut
le risque zéro n'existe pas il faut être
réaliste et il faut être honnête il y
aura des faillites il y en avait avant
il y en aura un petit peu plus parce que
les conditions sont beaucoup plus
restrictive même si l'état a décidé le
sait le fameux quoi qu'il en coûte du
président de la république au printemps
l'état a décidé de couvrir au maximum
les pertes d'exploitation
les pertes de l'ailé perte d'activité
des entreprises des pme et des tpe des
indépendants qui vont être impactés par
ce nouveau call of
et puis l'idée c'est de protéger en
restant chez soi et surtout en abaissant
ses actes le nombre de ces interactions
sociales dans une semaine par exemple
mais le medef de son côté le medef
premier syndicat des patrons et des
chefs d'entreprise lui ils dénoncent
d'ores et déjà le télétravail accrue
donc est ce qu'on n'est pas finalement
dans une dans une impasse entre cet
équilibre protection de la santé des
français et protection de l'économie et
des emplois je dirais oui et non je
répondrais comme un normand oui oui non
le président a été a été relativement
clair ils sont où il a tenu compte des
enseignements du printemps au moment du
confinement où il y avait pu avoir cette
confusion entre on confie dont ray chez
soi mais il faut continuer à travailler
donc là le président a dit la règle de
base c'est qu'il faut continuer à
travailler
donc ça veut dire que les entreprises
doivent continuer de fonctionner les
salariés doivent continuer à aller
travailler et ça c'est important
le télétravail c'est déshumanisant pour
les gens qui ont font trop parce que ça
peut provoquer plus de mal que de bien
donc il dit il faut simplement à faire
de preuve de bon sens le travail en
collectif dans une entreprise c'est
important on ne doit pas casser cette
cette émulation
cette alchimie qu'il ya dans une équipe
entre des personnes donc le télétravail
il doit être maintenue il doit être
privilégiée mais pas généralisée
alors c'est sûr que vous allez me dire
c'est très subtil grosso modo il a donné
cette recette bornes cette référence
cette jauge en maturité et travail il
faut que lorsque c'est possible
il n'y ait pas plus de deux ou trois
jours de télétravail par semaine et par
personne
mais encore faut-il que l'emploi s'ils
s'y prête encore faut-il qu'on soit dans
une zone effectivement couverte par dans
une zone où le virus circule de manière
active
mais il faut que les locaux s'y prête
donc et donc c'est très aléatoire il n'y
a pas de norme généralisée il n'y a pas
de règles nationales et le président est
là pour le coup il a moi je pense qu'il
a raison
il a dit très clairement on ne peut pas
imposer une règle nationale en matière
de télétravail parce que toutes les
situations sont différentes et c'est au
niveau de chaque entreprise que via le
dialogue social
on doit trouver le meilleur dispositif
la meilleure négociation le meilleur
cadre pour appliquer ce télétravail dans
l'entreprise donc grosso modo ça veut
dire démerdez vous démerdez vous
entreprise par entreprise
là vous pouvez et edu pouvait faire du
télétravail faites-le là vous pouvez pas
vous le limiter mais faites en sorte que
ça se développe un petit peu sans que ça
devienne majoritaire parce que la vie en
collectif dans une entreprise c'est
important et c'est ça qui fait qu'on va
continuer à vivre en société et à vivre
ensemble
une question qui nous vient de twitch
orge stewart qui je suis ravi de
retrouver sur son autre chaîne quelqu'un
peut-il expliquer comment un couvre-feu
réduira les 4 go vide si les restaurants
sont des vecteurs
pourquoi ne pas les fermer est ce que le
but du jeu n'est pas donné peu n'est pas
de 2,2 de tuer ou des noues de
d'annihiler toute vie sociale
les restaurants ne sont pas des vecteurs
de multiplication du coc vide ils sont
des v notamment lorsque des protocoles
sanitaires sont bien appliquées le
problème c'est de la multiplication des
interactions c'est le fait que quand
vous allez au restaurant vous allez
prendre les transports en commun vous
allez voir d'autres personnes qui sont
peut être infecté donc vous multipliez
le risque et ça veut pas dire que vous
multipliez la propagation du virus si
vous multipliez le risque que le virus
se diffuse
c'est pas parce que vous allez dîner au
restaurant où vous avez déjeuné au
restaurant avec des amis ou avec des
collègues que forcément vous allez
attraper le coc vigoux vous à les
diffuser
sinon on fermerait le restaurant dans
les zones a voulu si le virus se pile
activement y compris le midi on
interdirait les cafétérias ou les
cantines d'entreprises y compris midi ce
n'est pas le cas le but du jeu c'est ça
c'est vraiment de freiner la circulation
du virus c'est de casser cette chaîne
qui fait que le virus se propage de
personne en personne
à partir du moment où on multiplie les
interactions sociales en cassant le
nombre de d'interactions sociales
on peut espérer freiner la
multiplication du virus
et puis on rappellera un de façon
pédagogique on peut être en pleine forme
et se rendre à une soirée et est
asymptomatique et et transmettre le
virus est ce que marseille est touché
par le couvre feu nous demande kane sur
youtube effectivement la métropole d'aix
marseille fait partie bien de ses huit
métropoles
dans lesquelles un couvre-feu s'applique
entre 21h et 6h à partir de samedi qu'al
sur twitch intéressante cette question
aussi pour l'aide aux jeunes dont
emmanuel macron a parlé parce qu'il a
effectivement parlé d'une à nos jeunes
est ce que ce sera valable pour tous les
jeunes ou bien seulement pour les
boursiers
il a parlé il a dit de le brainois dit
deux choses il a d'abord rappelé le
dispositif qui a été pris dès le mois
d'août qui s'appelle un jeune une
solution c'est 6 milliards et demi
d'euros qui ont été mis en place pour
créer des formations supplémentaires
pour créer des emplois aidés
supplémentaires pour faciliter les
recrutements en apprentissage et dans
les entreprises
donc il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de
dispositifs supplémentaires qui est
prévu dans le cadre de ce de ceux de ce
programme
un jeune une solution en revanche ce
qu'a dit le président et ça ça concerne
une partie des jeunes peut-être les
boursiers en tout cas certains boursiers
c'est qu'il a dit que pour les
bénéficiaires du rsa comme pour les
bénéficiaires des apl est donc dans les
bénéficiaires des apl il y a des
boursiers des étudiants boursiers
le dispositif qui a été mis en place
pendant le confinement à savoir d'une
prime exceptionnelle de 150 euros
je vérifie parce que je parle whist 250
euros plus 100 euros par enfant à charge
six enfants il y a va être apporté dans
les semaines qui viennent
ça veut dire que c'est pas c'est pas une
prime par mois c'est à dire qu'on va
faire un chèque supplémentaire à ces
publics qui sont plutôt en difficulté
dont on sait que ce sont ceux qui
souffrent le plus de la crise
actuellement parce que c'est ce qu'ont
perdu leur emploi ou c'est ceux qui ont
le plus de mal à se mouvoir ou ceux qui
sont les plus fragiles en matière de
santé donc on va leur donner 100 euros
en one shot pour permettre de passer ce
petit cap et 150 plus pendant 150 euros
plus 100 euros par enfant dont dans ce
lot là pour répondre à la question de
l'internaute
oui il y aura des étudiants boursiers
mais il faudra être soit bénie soit en
l'occurrence pour les étudiants
boursiers
il faudra bénéficier des appels voilà
pour cette réponse très complète de marc
landré à mon cher colle sur twitch merci
en tout cas d'avoir posé cette question
parce qu'il n'a pas été
que question du couvre-feu tendance
cette interview d'emmanuel macron il a
aussi été question tient des français
qui peuvent partir en vacances à la
toussaint bon ben ça on le savait déjà
depuis plusieurs jours mais c'est
confirmé est ce que c'est une manière
aussi de les soulager mentalement et de
sauver l'économie
quelque part le chef de l'état fait
référence aux locations de vacances par
exemple
là aussi un marc landré quel est votre
votre regard votre analyse sur cette
question des vacances de la toussaint
il est là le tourisme a beaucoup
souffert depuis maintenant six mois
on le sait de là cette crise du
coronavirus donc qu'il faut tout faire
pour éviter qu'ils souffrent encore plus
malheureusement le virus circule on voit
qu'il a un impact économique évidemment
sur ce secteur donc il faut ne pas
désespérer et faire en sorte que il
continue cela dit il ya des le le
couvre-feu ne couvre pas l'intégralité
du territoire français donc vous pouvez
partir en vacances les franciliens ou
légendes et mettre les habitants des
métropoles concernées peuvent partir en
dehors de ceux de deux de ces zones où
il ya des restrictions de liberté sur
les restaurants ont sur la vie à partir
de 21h le soir
cela dit il faut bien il faut pas
oublier une chose
l'activité économique continue pourquoi
parce que la grande différence par
rapport au printemps c'est qu'on a des
masques donc en toute période en toutes
situations à tout moment il faut porter
son masque et ça on sait que c'est la
meilleure des protections par rapport à
la propagation du virus
2 on a une politique de tests qui même
si elle est encore imparfaite allait
quand même beaucoup plus développé que
ce qu'elle était avant
donc en cas de problème on peut se faire
tester le président a parlé de nouveaux
tests qui allait arriver sur le marché
dans les semaines à venir
jusque là cette borne de l'été prochain
qui vont me permettre de se tester soi
même c'est chez soi au même titre qu'il
existe des tests de grossesse pour
savoir si une femme est enceinte on
pourra demain dans l'est dans les
prochaines semaines se tester coville
or note qu vide chez soi donc ça c'est
le deuxième point qui est important par
rapport à la période du printemps
et puis troisièmement vous avez des
protocoles sanitaires qui ont été mis en
place dans tous les lieux collectifs de
vie
les spl le sport dans les stades dans
tous les lieux culturels dans la vie en
entreprise
donc vous avez un centre de protocole
qui doivent être appliquées pour faire
en sorte que le virus ne se propage pas
donc c'est pour ça qu'on peut quand tu
peux partir en vacances que le président
aussi pour ne pas désespérer encore
toute une population qui est
structurellement déjà très pessimistes
ne va pas leur dire pour les
infantiliser plus qu'ils ne le sont déjà
restez chez vous je vous interdit de
sortir n'allez pas voir papier lit
d'ailleurs il a donné l'exemple de papy
mamie a dit effectivement les vacances
de la toussaint pour beaucoup dans
beaucoup de familles c'est l'occasion
pour les petits enfants d'aller voir
leurs grands parents mais pourrait vite
donc il n'interdit pas les visites chez
les grands parents
il dit simplement attention les grands
parents sont ils sont une population à
risque
on le sait les statistiques le
démontrent 85% des personnes qui sont
décédées ont plus de 65 ans donc ça
alerte s'est pas c'est un fait ça veut
dire quelque chose
donc si vous allez voir vos grands
parents s'il ya des réunions de famille
si possible pas à plus de 6 et bien dans
ce cas là il faut que tout le monde
porte le masque et qu'on se lave les
mains très régulièrement et pas de
câlins pas de bisous oui ça c'est la
contrainte malheureusement on pourra pas
le faire même avec un masque mais ses
dires est quelque part c'est un moindre
mal ou c'est mieux que rien donc on
n'interdit pas les déplacements on
n'interdit pas les vacances on
n'interdit pas d'aller voir papis et
mamies non on n'oublie pas qu'on est
dans une période où le virus circule et
qu'il faut qu'on casse propagation donc
on fait attention et c'est la grande
différence par rapport au printemps
quelles preuves recherche ou autre y à
t'il que le couvre-feu un change quelque
chose va le chef de l'état a cité
l'exemple de la guyane où le couvre-feu
est en vigueur de bâle depuis plusieurs
mois déjà depuis le printemps alors il
s'est allégé maintenant c'est entre
minuit et 5h du matin me semble-t-il est
d'après une étude à laquelle l'institut
pasteur est bien à contribuer le
couvre-feu a permis de réduire de plus
d'un tiers le taux de transmission du
virus un exemple là aussi utilisé par
par le chef de l'état il faut pas
oublier que le couvre
il ya eu un couvre-feu pendant le
confinement au printemps dans certaines
villes où le virus circule énormément
je pense notamment à nancy donc le
couvre feu n'est pas une nouveauté en
france
en période pour des questions sanitaires
dans le cadre de cette épidémie de
l'accord ou du coronavirus ça a été le
cas au printemps dans certaines villes
et ça a marché
centaine de villes c'est ce que j'avais
à dire effectivement l'impression que
c'est un gros mot aujourd'hui mais en
fait c'est parce que ça touche des
grosses villes des métropoles même une
région entière comme l'ile-de-france
mais effectivement on parlait de nancy
avec béziers nice où il y avait même eu
des recours devant la justice un devis
qui avait pris assez tôt ces mesures de
couvre feu on va reparler aussi avant de
conclure de l'échec de ce top cow vide
et de cette nouvelle application qui va
arriver le 22 octobre 1 confirme hélas
aussi par emmanuel macron est-ce qu'on a
une idée marc landry du coût de l'échec
de ce top cow vie d'un gilles bouleau de
tf1 a parlé de moins de 500 personnes
qui ont été prévenus
ce jour sur l'application un prévenu
qu'elle était qu'à contacter on a une
idée un pour les finances pour le le
coût pour le contribuable français de
cet échec
je ne sais plus là ce n'est pas le
chiffre en tête du coût de développement
de 2,2 de stock co vide ça doit à mon
avis se mesurer en quelques dizaines
voire centaines de millions et je dirais
quelque part au vu de vos vues de ce que
va coûter cette crise au niveau global
macro des limites nationales et
internationales c'est une goutte d'eau
dans la mer donc c'est pas le problème
il est pas là ce que j'ai ce que j'ai
trouvé un peu surprenant de la part du
chef de l'état quand même lorsqu'il nous
a parlé de cette nouvelle application
qui va s'appeler tous contre covit je
crois de tout ce top cow vie depuis
guettés mans mais c'est le fait qu'ils
aient grosso modo outre le fait qu'il y
aura des informations sur l'état de
circulation du virus dans la zone ou du
territoire vous êtes des endroits où se
faire tester c'est très bien ça c'est du
service yale
ça ne s'est peut être ça ne peut être
qu'un plus c'est très bien il faudra
l'activé quand vous allez dans une
réunion lorsque vous allez rencontrer
des gens donc ça veut dire qu'on va
demander aux gens d'être proactif et de
systématiquement déclenché connaissant
les français je suis pas sûr que ce
flicage ou ce qu'ils risquent de prendre
comme un cliff un flicage volontaire de
leur part en activant l'application à
chaque fois qu'ils vont restaurants qui
vont dans une rencontre où qui a la
possibilité de d'interagir avec d'autres
personnes
je suis pas sûr que l'efficacité soit au
rendez vous si on demande une démarche
volontaire et automatique de la personne
qui doit activer son appli demain voilà
j'ai une petite réserve sur sur
l'efficacité de ce futur dispositif
maintenant le président a été très clair
il a dit que si on compare par rapport à
aux autres aux autres aux autres pays
c'est vrai nous on a eu un double échec
c'est que ça on a les français n'ont pas
fait confiance à cette appli et donc
n'ont pas téléchargé et donc de fait il
ya eu très peu de personnes ont été
informées et qu'on était quand il apprit
a pu fonctionner cela dit dans les
autres pays basque est à ce qu'a dit le
président beaucoup de gens ont
téléchargé mais c'est pas pour autant
qu'il ya plus d'informations qu'on été
communiqué justement la comparaison avec
les autres pays et on va conclure là
dessus puisque je vois que ça parle
beaucoup de la suède dans le tchat sur
lefigaro.fr avec avec respect avec arcus
guy avec lucioles encore kill qui sont
avec nous ce confinement total du
printemps suivi de deux d'un couvre-feu
maintenant dans les principales
métropoles françaises
est ce qu'on a pu voir ça dans
dans d'autres pays par exemple oui oui
bien sûr aujourd'hui vous avez des
villes vous avez des pays où il ya du
coup il ya des côtés des couvre feux
sont son temps sont en place en
allemagne notamment berlin et on voit
que la preuve de la propagation du virus
effréné du fait de ces pays qui ont un
petit peu plus avance sur nous alors est
ce que parce que est ce parce qu'ils ont
réagi plus vite et qu'ils ont pris des
décisions qui s'imposaient plus tôt
c'est possible on a bien vu que lorsque
il ya eu non pas un couvre-feu même
c'était pas un cours aux faits mais
lorsqu'il a été lorsque la décision de
fermer les bars et les restaurants à
marseille a été prise il ya maintenant
trois semaines
on sait que c'est une proposition qui
avait été faite une semaine ou quinze
jours plus tôt par le conseil
scientifique et par olivier ferrand et
que politiquement il avait été décidé de
ne pas aller dans ce sens tout de suite
donc on a réagi sur aix marseille avec
un jour de retard par rapport à la
première préconisation
je crois que après faut faut être lucide
on apprend en marchant au fur et à
mesure oui il faut il faut tenir compte
et il faut benchmark et avec des pays
étrangers parce que y importer ce qui
marche
maintenant c'est pas parce qu'on va
importer ou qu'on va se se baser sur une
bonne initiative qui a été prise en
allemagne en grande-bretagne en espagne
que ça va fonctionner en france il ya
des questions culturelles
il ya des questions géographique il ya
des questions économiques qui font
qu'une bonne idée à l'étranger peut ne
pas se révéler être bonne en france donc
il faut vraiment adapté faire au mieux
dans le meilleur des cas sachant que ben
on n'est jamais à l'abri de se planter
pas mal de questions aussi sur youtube
d'internautes qui nous rejoignent en
cours de route et qui nous
bien s'interroge sur les écoles est ce
que les écoles ferment on referme
justement l'objectif c'est de maintenir
ouverts tous les établissements écoles
collèges lycées et les crèches aussi
l'idée c'est vraiment l'idée il faut
bien soin de retenir c'est dans les
zones où le virus circule le plus
activement donc l'ile-de-france plus les
huit grandes métropoles pour faire pour
pour faire simple c'est de faire en
sorte que l'on casse la circulation du
virus
le soir et la nuit si là où il ya le
plus de risques que les gestes barrières
soient délaissés soient mises de côté
les soirées entre copains les dîners en
famille et bien on met pas le masque on
est plus proches les uns des autres
donc c'est là où il ya un risque de
multiplication de propagation plus
rapide du virus donc c'est cette chaîne
là qu'on veut casser ce n'était pas là
l'autre chaîne c'est pas la chaîne ou
des protocoles sanitaires s'applique à
l'école ou en entreprise dans les
transports en commun là où ça fonctionne
on continue mais là où on voit qu'il ya
du relâchement là où on voit qu'il ya
des problèmes
là on essaie de casser cette chaîne et
c'est donc essentiellement le soir à
partir de 21h rigueur débat est-ce que
c'était 20 heures est-ce que c'était 21h
le gouvernement a tranché les taaf a
tranché c'est 21h ça veut pas dire que
si ça ne fonctionne pas on amène on
anticipera pas à 20h ou qu'on ne dans
les semaines qui viennent on ne dira pas
par exemple je pense à bordeaux pour
d'eau qui était en zone d' alerte il ya
quelques ya il ya quelques jour qui sait
a bien rétabli la la la la la la barque
ça veut pas dire que bordeaux rhône ne
rentrera pas dans cette catégorie là
deux villes de métropole sous couvre-feu
dans les 10 15 20 30 prochains jours si
jamais la situation nécessite
merci beaucoup marc landré rédacteur en
chef du service économie france au
figaro bien d'avoir décrypter cette
prise de parole du chef de l'état prise
de parole que vous pouvez retrouver sur
lefigaro.fr je vais vous montrer ça tout
de suite on a le live texte
vous pouvez retrouver les annonces vous
êtes encore nombreuses et nombreux à
nous poser cette question sur youtube
est-ce qu'on ait reconquis nos panneaux
renom il y à un couvre-feu qui est mis
en place à partir de samedi entre 21h et
6h du matin en région ile de france et
dans huit métropoles à savoir li
rouen lyon saint-etienne grenoble aix
marseille montpellier et toulouse et
puis un mot aussi sur notre sondage nous
avons lancé un sondage sur le compte
twitter de figure au live approuvez-vous
justement cette instauration d'un couvre
feu de 21 heures à 6 heures en ile de
france et dans huit métropoles
vous pouvez encore voter pour l'instant
vous n'approuvez pas cette mesure à 84%
vous êtes donc plus de huit sur dix à ne
pas approuver l'actualité et à vivre
toujours sur figaro live sur youtube sur
twitter et bien sûr sur lefigaro.fr très
bonne soirée à toutes et à tous